everyone's outnumbered me I'm kind of
like lost in the shuffle but it's a lot
of fun we're really enjoying it Kris
Jenner is a proud grandma of Ted the
latest addition to the grandkids squad
Kim and Kanye's son Psalm West the
inspiration was the Book of Psalms in
the Bible so I think it's just a
wonderful way to celebrate you know how
they feel and he's such a blessing so
it's perfect it's just adorable it's
been a big year for the famous family
Kim welcomed a new baby Kylie launched a
skincare line is it something that
Kylie's been passionate about and just
one of her dreams really proud of her
and Khloe stayed strong as she learned
her boyfriend Tristan Thompson allegedly
cheated on her with Jordan Woods it just
sucks it has to be so public I'm not
just a TV show like this is my life it's
always difficult when somebody goes
through a rough time and I think one of
the things that has made the success of
the show is that we are you know show
those vulnerabilities and we're also
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded and what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story and they don't
Tristan might love me whatever that
means he has no respect for me
whatsoever the rest of the season has so
many crazy things going on and as I say
every time you guys ask it's just tune
in because you never know what's gonna
happen but no matter how crazy life gets
the Kardashians are never too busy to
give back
et caught up with Chris at the fresh air
funds annual spring benefit honoring
Tommy Hilfiger 20 years and it's really
important and I'm really just happy to
be here to help him celebrate all the
kids who benefit from everything year
round you know for all the things that
he's done over the years Tommy's always
so generous and gives to so many
different organizations but I think one
of the things that's so near and dear to
as hard as the kids the mentoring and
the educational benefits and the
friendships that these kids make over
the years and it's exciting
[Music]